I have a message for progressives okay
and this relates to this entire move to
Canada don't move to Canada etcetera
etcetera progressives need to be as
strategic and pragmatic as possible now
going forward into the 2017
gubernatorial elections the 2018
midterms the 2020 election census and
following redistricting and the 2022
election we've already talked about the
national popular vote interstate compact
which is the idea that instead of states
voting electorally for the winner within
their state they would instead agree to
cast their electoral votes for the
winner of the popular vote okay we
talked about that yesterday I'm not
going to rehash it now check out that
segment on youtube if that's interesting
to you we've also talked about moving to
Canada and the reality is even though
I'm going to move to Canada is something
that many people more progressive than
conservatives say depending on what
election results are very few people
move to Canada and it's also very very
difficult to do the easiest way would be
to marry a canadian but by and large
it's not that easy to move to canada
there's another idea which i think makes
a lot more sense if you're in the camp
of those who would be willing to move
because of election results move to a
swing state I know that lots of swing
states seem like no place for liberals
but there are lots of swing states that
have increasingly liberal areas Texas
has austen in Texas could be a future
purple state georgia has I think
Savannah and Athens are sort of liberal
there's also Atlanta general big cities
tend to be relatively liberal another
possible future state swing state but we
also have current swing states with nice
areas in florida i love miami and miami
beach in north carolina you've got
asheville and the Research Triangle
Wisconsin has Milwaukee I've never been
but many friends say it's really a great
spot there's no guarantee that moving to
a swing state will cause electoral
change but it has more of a shot of
improving the u.s. than just bailing and
moving to Canada even if you could Pat
which is very difficult to do so I think
if you're in the camp of those who want
to move because of politics have an
impact and go to a swing state or
another idea would just be to move from
a
red state to a blue state towards the
end of the decade because that'll
increase a representation here for the
next census you can work simultaneously
on the National popular vote uh
initiative interstate compact and move
to a red state if you want I I really
would have trouble though I don't think
this is anything I could ever really do
I be like I could definitely see myself
living in Miami or Miami Beach like I
said lots of the other places i
mentioned i don't really see myself
living in but i also don't see myself
living in most of Canada other than
montreal quebec city Toronto and
possibly Vancouver although I've never
actually been I think that when people
react emotionally and say effects
happens I'm moving here or there
sometimes it's not really taking
seriously the magnitude of what it is to
relocate as someone who did it when I
was five and it was in many ways very
difficult and very traumatic of course i
had the language barrier which wouldn't
exist if you move to uh texas or north
carolina or or wherever i think
sometimes we have these emotional
reactions and we're not really
considering it for for what it is
although there are always some people
who do move to canada after all an
election my question would be how many
of them were already sort of thinking
about moving to canada regardless of
election results consider if you are a
progressive move to a swing state turn
some red states purple or purple States
blue really could be a something that
actually causes electoral change much
more than just bailing and going to
Canada what I've talked about how people
of all ages but particularly Millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is zip car
which gets you a car when you want it
when you need it they offer all sorts of
cars SUVs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David